you know society rewards overconfidence
we want our leaders to be overconfident
I mean if they told us the truth about
the uncertainty we would discard them in
favor of other leaders who who sort of
give an impression that they know what
they're doing we want overconfidence we
support it we sustain it and there is an
awful lot of it I mean most of what we
read in the paper is overconfidence
sometimes it's catastrophic just about
every war that you see I think that's a
general rule there are optimists among
the generals and there are optimists on
both sides and and that is true for a
lot of litigation as well so a lot of
conflict is fed by overconfidence there
is an interesting story here of two
biases that work in opposite directions
so one familiar you can call it bias but
is what we call loss of those people put
a lot more weight on negative events
than on positive events on lawson's than
on gains so that's one principle that
you know if if people are to gamble many
on the toss of a coin and and they stand
to lose $100 they will demand more than
$200 to accept the gamble which is in
some ways ridiculously risk-averse so
people are loss of moves on the other
hand they're optimistic and so many of
the decisions that people make
especially installing new businesses I
mean that is where it's been studied
most extensively people think they will
succeed they open a restaurant because
they think they will succeed but in fact
less than 1/3 of small businesses
survive for five years
so clearly overconfidence is rife and
overconfidence and loss aversion seem to
be acting in opposite directions you
have to distinguish the perspective of
the individual from the perspective of
society I think for society it is
probably very good that we have a lot of
optimistic entrepreneurs and you know
who think they will succeed although
most of them fail
and most of them really do not know the
odds it is not true that they know the
odds and they take the risks willingly
but many of them most of them probably
do not know the odds from the point of
view of the individuals it is not always
good to be optimistic for example I have
no interest whatsoever in my financial
advisor being an optimist you know I
don't care for that for an entrepreneur
it may be a good thing to be an optimist
because it will make him or her
persevere more we know that being an
optimist is useful under some conditions
it is not always useful in making
decisions